if you have social anxiety and you the
thought of public speaking terrifies you
and your boss says hey you got to give
the presentation at the board meeting
there's a consequence to that right you
can get fired or they may be like oh my
gosh you blew it that's for real hanging
out with friends on the
weekend maybe less for real right so
it's going to be context dependent but
asking yourself what do you think people
are going to find out what am I nervous
for them to see and what is the worst
thing that can happen literally very
specifically are they really going to
leave me good for them get out of my
life I don't want them anyway what is it
about me that my body's trying to
protect them from finding out about